do you have like are there any like big
mistakes that you made in the beginning
that you would tell someone not to make
it's a funny thing to say no I probably
made 800 they're just so they're so
irrelevant I think the biggest mistake
not to make is to not invest in your
business too many people start a service
business
and the money they make
they use to pay for their lifestyle when
they're still in the beginning
I didn't buy 27 martinis
that's the Fatal flaw of a young
business not putting money back into
business the number one flaw is not
hiring somebody as fast as possible
because you're spending that money
on the night on the town whether that's
expensive coffee or Ubers or actually
nights on the town because you're young
and you want to but what you're doing is
you're not feeding your business you
know you may be feeding your you know
your your your your your
insecurities you might be feeding your
vanity you might be feeding a needed
break here and there but too many people
waste money that the business is
bringing to them on their on themselves
instead of feeding the business
how many thousand dollar clients do you
have
so six perfect so you have six one
thousands paying you one thousand a
month and two forty five hundreds right
yeah on the six one thousands think
about this if you go to all of them and
say how how long is your contract with
them
usually six months great if you give
them the preview now
if you go to three of them three of the
six
right and you say hey
just to give you an FYI when we're up
given how much demand I have I just want
to be forthcoming I need to bring you up
to 4 000 a month forty five hundred
three thousand but at least three
thousand with the three if one of them
say yes
you've paid
for the other two saying no and them
leaving
right yeah if two of them say yes and by
taking three of the six you're not
putting yourself in a bad spot that
you're losing six thousand a month
so the first thing you should do
immediately is take the three of the six
that you currently have that are the
going the best
and tell them that when we I want to
give you as much time as possible Sally
Ricky and Johnny
that when this expires I need to take
you to 3 500 4 000 or 4500 a month
uh so I want to give you time to be
prepared if you need to do something
else
right
yeah no that makes sense it makes me
nervous because like they fought me on
like the 1000 a month well you know well
it did all six force fight you on one
thousand a month
yeah good well here's the good news the
good news is
they just might be good at negotiating
right
when I go to a garage sale
and someone has something for twenty
three dollars and I offer two dollars
I if they say yes that's up to them but
I would have paid 15.
they might have fought you for a
thousand but in the back of their mind
they might have been willing to go to
2500 but now you're going on offense and
saying I'm 3 000 or you're gonna or
we're not gonna work together if you do
that right now think about the worst
case scenario you only took three people
they could all tell you to go [ __ ]
yourself you still are gonna work with
them they could even fire you the next
day sure you lost 3 000 but but if you
think about it there's so much more
upside than downside for you plus you're
also producing content on LinkedIn and
Tick Tock to create more leads that may
lead to people from day one paying you
three to five thousand you have to go on
the offense on this yeah no and I'm very
I definitely undersell myself like I
always because they're so reactive to a
thousand dollars I'm like am I too
expensive I'm pretty sure I'm very cheap
considering like industry standard yeah
I mean look there is there is no
industry standards on like social media
create you know social like 1550
000 like it can run the game it can run
the gamut it this is this becomes a game
of letting yourself focus on fear versus
optimism
instead of saying I'm gonna lose you're
talking about six clients
right there's 66 trillion clients out
there Maurice
they know so so you need to you need to
really get focused I'm telling you I'm
giving you the I'm getting I'm not
giving you fluffy macro ideas I'm giving
you exactly what I would do you have six
clients paying you a thousand you want
all of them to get to three four five
thousand you take three of them the
three best ones that are going right now
in your opinion and you send them an
email and set up a phone call and you
tell them I want to give you as much
time as possible some of them might
since they sound like they're six
monthers some might be expiring in two
months some might be three months I'm
giving you as much time as possible I'm
getting too much demand
my business is evolving
yeah and I you know I want to give you
the preview that's gonna be three
thousand dollars a month if you want to
continue with me at the end of the
contract
and you know I really appreciate you and
so I want to help you find someone else
if that's not in the cards but I'd love
to continue to work with you
yeah no that makes sense
um I mean I feel like even my clients
sometimes they'll say they're not happy
with me but they continue to work with
me and right because some because some
because clients
rightfully because they're doing what's
right for their business sometimes we'll
complain as negotiation tactic
yeah you just have to get into your mind
that you're okay with giving up these
three thousand dollars a month
because you may lose them anyway at the
end anyway right you might lose it
anyway but you're gonna learn a lot from
the process of telling three clients
you're going from a thousand to four
thousand
right
no that makes sense
and then like in terms of like getting
new clients and like setting
expectations I do think I've gotten
better at it but I feel like you know
clients come to me and they expect the
world and I I can't give them that you
know in in two months you you just can't
[ __ ] we do it all the time at Vayner
we're like look
we're you know we're good but we're not
[ __ ] The Wizard of Oz
yeah you know like like you can't for
two thousand dollars in two months you
can't get a local barber shop 600 new
clients
yeah exactly
and I'm pretty upfront with people and I
think that's why they like working with
me except I'm just honest yeah but at
your level and it's the biggest mistake
people make when they have a service
business that is getting paid a little
and when they're building up they over
promise because they want the money so
much but then they're going to lose the
client and it's going to be ruined
anyway you're better off them all saying
no than saying yes to [ __ ] right no
that makes a lot of sense
um I have no online presence and I'm
sure that's not good right well you know
like I don't think there's a game of
good or not good I think it's a missed
opportunity for you to get inbound
emails saying I'd like to work with you
if you make a tick tock right now saying
this is a trend I'm seeing on Tick Tock
that small businesses can take advantage
of and you have your email and your
website linked in your bio
it's going to be a lot easier to tell
people that are paying you a thousand
bucks that they need to pay you 4 000
when you have 17 new business calls on
Tuesday
right
no that's true yeah so do I believe it
is a missed opportunity yes I believe it
is a missed opportunity what content
should you make on LinkedIn and Tick
Tock specifically I think you'll find
very fruitful opportunities Facebook
reels as well as exploding YouTube
shorts as well use the same content
everywhere which I hate but when you're
a one-woman show you might have to do
that at first where you can maybe change
the copy that's associated with the
video but put out things that you're
seeing in the marketplace
mm-hmm it's what I'm doing right now I'm
telling you that Facebook reels are
exploding
you know I knew of you because of all
the content yeah it's the metam this
entire conversation right
I think you should I think you should
it's how you get more clients
I know like I'm definitely uncomfortable
on video but I'm sure I just have to
like the practice I'll get better at it
yeah and don't forget your words are
what matters plus you can come up with a
gimmick right like [ __ ] like
I've been waiting for somebody to
marshmallow it in social media advice
like literally wear an emoji over their
face and be like the social media
content whisper and she or he can have a
big business because people like like
people would think about how people
would get if you're making good content
where you've got like a mask or a helmet
or a filter and
the and but you're actually willing to
do business with people like how much
fun they would have in the first few
minutes of the meeting just talking
about like oh my God I can't believe
it's you like I was curious what you
look like like it almost puts you on
third base to close the deal
no the mask the masked expert
and by the way back to expert speak like
you're an Enthusiast not an expert
expertise positioning is very very very
dangerous for a lot of people because it
leads them to imposter syndrome and
insecurity you don't need to be an
expert you need to be a practitioner
I'm in that that's what you do that's
what I do you know yeah I mean social
changes every day like you can't eat I'm
aware
yeah
which you have like are there any like
big mistakes that you made in the
beginning that you would tell someone
not to make
it's a funny thing to say no I probably
made 800. they're just so they're so
irrelevant I think the biggest mistake
not to make is to not invest in your
business too many people start a service
business
and the money they make
they use to pay for their lifestyle when
they're still in the beginning
I didn't buy 27 martinis
that's yeah that's the flavor that's the
Fatal flaw of a young business not
putting money back into business the
number one flaw is not hiring somebody
as fast as possible because you're
spending that money
on the night on the town whether that's
expensive coffee or Ubers or actually
nights on the town because you're young
and you want to but what you're doing is
you're not feeding your business you
know you may be feeding your you know
your your your your your
insecurities you might be feeding your
vanity you might be feeding a needed
break here and there but too many people
waste money that the business is
bringing to them on the on themselves
instead of feeding the business
[Music]